a US Army veteran is being held without
bail accused of plotting an attack in
California to avenge the killing of
Muslims 26 year-old mark Domingo faces
terrorism-related charges after his
arrest in an FBI sting prosecutors say
he planned to set off a bomb in Long
Beach on Sunday Domingo served a tour in
Afghanistan and recently converted to
Islam he allegedly talked about a series
of attacks throughout Southern
California
Jonathan Vigliotti is following this
alleged plot that officials say
developed very quickly Jonathan good
morning to you and good morning to you
Gael federal prosecutors say Domingo
wanted to punish Americans for attacks
on Muslims around the world
investigators believe he worked alone
for two months and was in the final
stages of this plan they say that they
were monitoring him 24/7 leading up to
his arrest sometimes we get asked what
keeps you up at night this is a case
that keeps us up at night investigators
say the arrest of mark Domingo prevented
revenge fueled bloodshed law enforcement
was able to identify a man consumed with
hate and bent on mass murder and stop
him prosecutors allege the 26-year old
Army veteran planned to detonate a bomb
Sunday at a white nationalist rally in
Long Beach California but he was
arrested Friday after taking possession
of what he thought was an AED from an
undercover FBI agent while scoping out a
spa in a park to plant the bomb the
explosive was a dummy
mr. Domingo said that he wanted to kill
Jews as they walked to synagogue at
other times he said he wanted to kill
and target police officers authorities
say the infantrymen who served a combat
stint in Afghanistan recently converted
to Islam and was quickly radicalized the
investigation began after the FBI saw an
apparent online post from Domingo saying
America needs another Vegas event to
give a taste of the terror they gladly
spread all over the world
he was referring to the 2017 mass
shooting in Las Vegas that killed 58
people
he also allegedly sought retribution for
last month's mass killing in New Zealand
I am speechless enthis James Domingo
says he thought his brother's religious
conversion helped him cope with personal
issues I thought maybe my brother
finally found some sort of guidance in
this world an authority said Domingo had
no prior criminal record Norah if he is
convicted he could face up to 15 years
in prison
great work by the FBI there Jonathan
thank you